[Music]
now as we have covered on this program
night after night far left ideologies
they are infiltrating our educational
system from grade school right through
college it's getting that bad
so bad that even those who have fled
from totalitarian regimes
seeking freedom in america in search of
freedom of thought
they're taking notice an actual defector
from north korea
who attended the ivy league institution
known as columbia university is speaking
out
telling foxnews.com the climate inside
colombia
reminds her of north korea citing themes
like
anti-western sentiment collective guilt
suffocating political correctness
for example during orientation she said
she was scolded
for saying that she enjoyed the works of
acclaimed author
jane austen and was told the books are
racist
along with being subjected to what she
saw as
nonstop anti-american propaganda here to
tell her story is north korea
defector yomi park along with fox news
contributor
uh mike huckabee um naomi i read this
story
you're you're saying so you grew up and
how many years you were in north korea
what 20 years and you think the
indoctrination in the united states
at our ivy league institution colombia
is as bad or worse as the propaganda
anti-american hate that you heard in
north korea
so when i was in north korea first thing
that i learned was that
americans were bastards it was actually
the one word
at school when i was attending they told
me
actually there's just math problems
saying there are four american
ambassadors
you killed two of them then how many
american ambassadors
left to care and as a child in north
korea you have to say two american
masters
and when i came to america a guy like i
fell in love with this country this is
such a wonderful country
i never been accepted more than this
country was
and as at columbia university literally
every professor
was saying that you know the problems
that we have on today's world is because
of white men
how they colonize africa they have
corazon i mean
asia right that's how they mess up
everything and they are the one who's
who needs to be blamed and i couldn't
believe that
am i sitting in north korea's classroom
or in america actually i couldn't
believe
why people were hating their own people
that much
what is your overall thought then when
you think of look at america today
and you compare with your life
experience which has been horrific
uh sold into sex slavery at one point in
your life
uh you get to america you're expecting
this to be the land of the free the home
of the brave and the land of freedom and
and you get the exact same propaganda
here
it's just heartbreaking i i literally
sold as a sexual slave
and i literally crossed the golby desert
to be free
and now i thought i i landed in a
country where i can
say what i believed and have my you know
freedom to think
however now i end up in a country i have
to constantly
censoring my speech because now in the
name of a safe place
colombia was told i mean told us what we
cannot talk about
yeah and i am so concerned like if
america is not free
i think there's no place else's life
that is free
and i think that's why it's really
alarming to me
listening my governor to ms park i'm
you know sometimes when you when you're
in the middle of what i call
incrementalism step by step
you know we now know what cancer culture
is woke america is
we now know what political political
what's politically incorrect and then to
hear
this it's it it doesn't really shock me
but hearing it still shocks me if that
makes any sense
well it makes a whole lot of sense i'll
tell you what would make a lot of sense
why don't you and i get her a tour bus
and we'll pay for it sean you and me and
we will send her to every college campus
in america
and let this remarkable young woman
speak
and tell her story and let people know
that what they're giving up in this
country
they're giving away something that they
can never get back and i'm so proud of
her
you have no idea how grateful i am for
the courage
and the clarity of yeonmi's story and i
just want to tell her
there are a lot of us who love america
who still believe in freedom and we
believe in you
and we're grateful that you're here and
your message
is one that i hope every single american
will hear
i know some of them won't those people
that you were taught to believe were the
american bastards well
they probably won't care but all of us
are not like that we really aren't
you should read some of mike's books
about southern sayings remember
alexander solzhenitsyn
i remember the speech i think i believe
if my memory serves me right he gave it
at uh harvard any and you know here's a
guy
from former soviet union saying you're
getting bad here too
and here's what you're doing wrong would
you consider
this trip this bus trip that governor
huckabee's talking about would you
consider talking to college campuses
although i've got to warn you you
probably would be protested and they try
to cancel you
and shut you down because that happens
as a conservative i can tell you
every conservative i know lives through
that experience would you consider that
though
so oh yeah i mean i'm i used to be enemy
was kim jong-un i mean i have been on
the killing list of kim jong-un for many
years
because i speak spoke out in the west
about the suffering of north korean
people
my three generations of family got
punished
but now it's ironically enough so many
marxists and communists
maoist leninists and sending me death
threats
and this is such a irony that i don't
even know how to respond
that this is a war that against
socialism and communism
the fact that i come from north korea
and saying
you know north korea started as a
communist country it began as
you know let's make the most equal
society in the world
now the regime made 50 different classes
based on your status based on what your
great great
grandfather did and when i went to
colombia that's when i shocked they say
because your ancestors owned the slaves
that you must be guilty
you are privileged because you're white
and this is injustice because you can
never choose your
ancestors you don't choose your your
race and people in north korea being
punished for
you know certain class and in this
america the same thing happening right
now
your your your testimony is powerful
you know the bible says the testimony of
two men are true
uh thank you for your courage omi thank
you mike huckabee thank you